coffee on a Tuesday and block 24 and to
everybody out there who's new well and
so there was the Soviet astronomer
called Nikolai Kardashev and he devised
a system for measuring the energy needs
of a civilization on a very broad scale
it's called the card - of scale and it
breaks down like this a type one
civilization is one that's harness the
full power of the planet on which it
lives which is to say a civilization
that utilizes all the solar wind nuclear
etc energy available to it on its home
planet this is measured using earth as
an example as 10 to the 16th watts as
type one civilization can control the
weather it can manipulate basic matter
and its economy is global now a type two
civilization is one that has harnessed
all the power from its nearest own when
the planets energy output becomes
unequal to the needs of the civilization
that civilization will go right to the
source and devise some method for
collecting the energy from that giant
fusion reactor which is its parent star
measured using the Sun as an example as
four times 10 to the 26 what a type two
civilization is for all intents and
purposes invincible there is nothing
known to physics not even a supernova
which can destroy it
now a type 3 civilization and this is
where it gets cool is one that has
harnessed all the power of its home
galaxy which is to say all the many
billions of stars that comprise it sort
of like the Galactic Republic from Star
Wars using our Milky Way as an example
this is measured at 4 times 10 to the
37th watts and then there's us human
beings from the planet Earth we are
drumroll please a type 0 civilization
which means that we still get the
majority of our energy from dead plants
how long will it take for us to become
type 1 Michio Kaku a physicist who you
might have seen on every single Science
Channel show has pretty good that we'll
get there somewhere in the next 100 to
200 years and type 2 in the next
thousand and we see the beginnings of
that now but there's a problem here and
it's it's out there in the stars in our
galaxy the Milky Way galaxy which has
somewhere between 200 to 400 billion
stars in it common sense seems to tell
us that there has to be intelligent life
out there somewhere most likely
intelligent life which
way more advanced than us we know that
any civilization type 2 or above would
have an energy signature detectable by
our instruments so the question has to
be why don't we see them there are many
possible answers to this question but
the one I find most compelling is the
one most applicable to our situation
here on earth every intelligent species
will go through the process of
discovering the elements on the periodic
table the work systematically from
hydrogen on up and eventually they'll
come to discovering element 92 known to
us as uranium this is a very special on
earth it appears in a few isotopes most
commonly uranium 238 now this consists
of ninety-nine point two percent of all
the uranium that's out there but there's
also uranium-235 now this consists of
0.72 percent of all that's out there but
it's much much more valuable
see when you bombard uranium 235 with
the free Neutron you make uranium 236 a
highly unstable atom so unstable that it
has to split into two lighter elements
Krypton and barium as well as three more
free neutrons this process is called
fission and it releases a whole lot of
energy how much energy well there's a
handy equation for figuring that out
it's simply the mass times the speed of
light square thing is it's very tricky
to separate that uranium-235 from the
uranium 238 takes a lot of time and a
lot of money but if you can do it that
remaining uranium 235 is called enriched
uranium and if you have a good amount of
it well then you've really hit the
jackpot remember those three free
neutrons coming off the original uranium
236 atom well they're going to whiz away
and bombard other uranium-235 atoms
turning them into 236 s which then split
apart again and release three free
neutrons each now you can either control
the speed of this chain reaction if you
want to utilize the power for something
like a city or you can just let the
reaction go as fast as at once and the
result of this is
on earth only the richest and smartest
countries have been able to develop a
nuclear weapon because of the
tediousness of enriching that uranium
but just last month it was discovered
that the country of Iran has begun that
process of enrichment and successfully
maybe many people want Iran to stop
enriching for fear that they're building
a bomb Iran says that's not what it's
doing and that it won't stop but people
don't seem to believe them though I
don't have the slightest idea why it's
all very tense right now but let me let
me bring this back to my point see when
an intelligent species learns to enrich
uranium element 92 it all of a sudden
gains the power to totally destroy its
own environment in other words to
destroy itself maybe this is the reason
why we don't see or hear from other
intelligent life in the cosmos maybe
it's because the most critical time for
any civilization is that transition
between type zero and type one a type
one civilization is global which means
that its economy is global as well as a
large part of its culture it has to be
tolerant communicative pluralistic it
has to rise above the monocultural
totalitarian often theistic belief in
ultimate conformity in other words it
has to be peaceful we can see that
though we possess a lot of
characteristics of a type one
civilization we're not quite there yet
totalitarianism still has it sanctuaries
it may very well be the case that there
are dozens of earth-like planets out
there with extinct intelligent
civilizations civilizations that fail to
negotiate that transition between type 0
and type 1 civilizations caught up in
their own weaknesses and if we make it
and one day far from now are flying
around the galaxy and come across one
that didn't there's no doubt to me that
will feel the profoundest sense of pity
because we would know that with a little
bit of knowledge and empathy and courage
it could have gone the other way